[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
welcome to the studio tour 2016 in 360
degrees so right off the bat you can
probably already tell you can look
around if you're in Google Chrome you
can drag around the window this actually
works best on a mobile device so if
you're on your phone you can literally
like look around what's next to you
what's behind you or if you have
something like this Google cardboard you
can put your phone in there and really
get immersive with it so that's what
this is for but yeah this is the studio
so a lot of you guys first saw it when
it was super empty it's a little bit
more full now with a whole bunch of
stuff so I'm going to show you around
the idea generally of having a studio
space for me that's not just my bedroom
is so number one it's a lot bigger it's
a lot more space for me to actually do
things and set things up but number two
it's two postings and bring things in
and that mix of videos a little more
interesting but yeah I guess first
things first I'm gonna go ahead and show
you guys this gear cabinet right here so
I guess I'll call it the gear chest this
is essentially the video gear and the
stuff I make videos about so over here
on the right hand side this is Ikea
built so actually took like a lot of
time to build this but this is all the
stuff that I use to make the videos so
those surfaces behind you and around you
are pretty clean so this is like the
camera the lenses the slider is actually
a really good organizational tool if I
know exactly what's in every drawer here
so I know exactly where sound is and
where batteries are but this is what I'm
using to make the videos a slider all
that stuff I'm going to try to leave
links in the description below to as
many of these things that I'm talking
about as possible so if you have any
questions or if you're wondering if you
can get your hands on this stuff the
links will be below so that's what
that's for but that's the right-hand
side now if I switch over here to the
left-hand side
you can see there's a lot of the stuff
that I'm making videos about so this is
stuff like okay all the phone boxes all
the tablets the the laptops the
headphones all that sort of stuff that's
all living in here one of the things I
get a lot is what are you supposed to do
with the devices once you're done using
them like once you're stopped using or
reviewing a phone I don't know either I
still have that question as well so
that's kind of why this drawer exists
but yeah that's that's kind of the idea
of the gear cabinet is to keep things
organized and off of surfaces so it
looks pretty for video all the time but
yeah there's plenty of stuff living in
here so that's the gear chest I guess
I'll go ahead and move on and I'll show
you guys something else this is an mkbhd
Edition poker table super unique
obviously you can't buy this exact table
but I'll leave a link to the makers of
this table below so if you want to check
that out that's there but there is a
meaning behind it being a poker table
obviously we don't really we talk tech
on this channel all the time but we
often don't consider the people that are
making the tech and the decisions they
make to make each phone and each tablet
that we use every single day so it's for
that reason kind of rare to see a
company take a real gamble and go all-in
on something like crazy like this new
thing we're seeing that I you might see
in an upcoming video these bezels phones
they look crazy but I love it I love the
risk they're taking so this table is not
just a place for people to come and lose
their money but it's also kind of a
reminder for me for the companies that
are taking those risks and doing things
a little bit differently so this is the
table now there's some DVI stuff some
foam but we can move right along and
check this out besides the carpet which
does great acoustically this is the
dream desk this you've probably seen not
only all over Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook and places I've shared it but
this is the entire thing so you have a
look at it this is a super unique piece
of furniture and the chair obviously is
pretty neat to have as well but yeah
this took a couple months to arrive and
this is super sweet to actually have
here I get two main questions with this
desk when people see it as number one
like what do you do with your feet on
this base here I just kind of kick up I
don't think it's a big deal it's wood
they can handle it's terrible
and number two can you put things way
over here on this side of the desk and
will they fall off or knock it over
no this desk is great it's super usable
it's weighted very heavily over here
it's got cable management and yes I
could put like an iMac over there and I
would stay fine it's great there's also
some art behind me there's some Phillips
hue bulbs in these lights and obviously
the art you can't get anywhere else
either there's a video light as well
I'll move on so this is the sort of a
lounge type of entertainment sort of
areas we could probably tell by the
sweet modular couch and a chair right
here but yeah this is kind of fun so
this is a 4k OLED TV it's amazing it's
beautiful but there's almost never any
actual TV signal going into it there's
no cable box here it's mostly just
Internet like streaming services and
stuff so YouTube there's an Apple TV
plugged in there's a ps4 there's an Xbox
one there's a chromecast but there's a
chromecast ultra and the mail coming
soon because that supports 4k and this
can also be like a nice area for virtual
reality testing so VR stuff you're kind
of watching one of the VR videos right
now that stuff's coming out all the time
vr gaming is awesome so that stuff could
be tested here all the time now I keep
talking about philips hue because they
have these smart light bulbs at the
philips you app installed on my phone
the benefit of that is I have full
control over all the lights in this that
are Philips you the light strip behind
the desk all that stuff over the app on
my phone so that's kind of a neat thing
there's also one other thing I want to
show you guys since I haven't actually
formally shown you on video yet is this
thing this Thank You this is the the
plaque that you get first surpassing a
million subscribers on YouTube so I just
want to say thanks for like that in
person so you can get that yeah but
other than that this is the sort of a
lounge area I guess easiest way to move
on oh by the way a lot of foam it helps
is great I'll move on so this is the
corner of the room that I definitely
spend the most physical time in right so
this is the editing Bay this is the
vocal booth this is everything first of
all this piece of equipment right here
can't forget it this is the Kessler
pocket jib Pro
and you've seemed like the overhead shot
so I'm going straight down with like the
unboxings and stuff you can do that with
a tripod but it's a lot easier to have a
dedicated tool where I can roll this
over to the desk or roll over to the
white surface and point it straight down
and it'll get that overhead shot so
that's sick
this is the Google jump VR rig that
we're shooting this video on right now
so this is what you guys are looking at
me through this is the rig what it looks
like is basically 16 GoPros all on this
sort of a platter thing all connected
with this sort of a wire of cables all
recording at the same time so that's why
you can walk around and look they're all
recording in a stereoscopic 3d image has
a facial microphone by zoom up top just
like that so there's no up facing camera
so you like lose the upper 30 degrees or
so video but those wide-angle lenses
that's what you guys look like when I'm
looking at the camera and talk to you
that's what you look like um and then
there's the desks a pair of next desks
over here some foam in the corner that
I've put up but this is the next desk
Tara you've probably seen this before
actually but what's neat about this is
it's a it's sort of the charging station
for all things so batteries charge here
there's wireless charging here and
there's a USB type a USB type-c EOC USB
I don't know lightning everything
charges here
the Apple watch charges here so this is
also a height-adjustable desk but I
don't really sit here because I'm
usually sitting at the mega desk this
right here this is the next desk
err pro with I guess it's an even larger
custom size it's larger than they
normally make maximum as incredible so
this is covered in production equipment
it's not a normal everyday setup but
it's a pair of aces 4k displays this
little shelf here thing I'll try to link
on Amazon people really like that twelve
terabyte read where I keep the final
finished files sennheiser HD 800 s
bicolor where I'm probably going to have
an entire dedicated set up just for the
production like in all is 8k glory like
just this as a normal video so thumbs up
if you want to see that but in the
meantime this is what it looks like when
it's on got a Philips hue lightstrip in
the back and all kinds of foam behind
and below it because I'm doing sound
editing here just as much as I am video
editing
Yamaha HS 8s on the side devices that
I'm testing and the 2013 trashcan Mac
Pro that I'm hoping gets updated very
soon at least at the time of the
recording of this yeah and so being on
an x desc
err Pro it is height adjustable so you
can see it's at a standing height right
now but if I move the chair out moves
down to a more appropriate sitting
height speakers come with it everything
comes with me and I go down to a sitting
height so if I'm editing and sitting
that's great by the standing preset as
well so anytime I'm standing and I'm not
editing for a long time that's when I
stand the chair down here is a Herman
Miller embody that slides by underneath
so it's super easy so this is pretty
pretty compact pretty clean some color
where black keyboard and everything I
like it it works for me that's where the
production of most of the videos you
watch or happening so that's pretty much
it that's the extent of the studio and
the way it looks now in 2016 obviously
all this is subject to change is going
to evolve as time goes on stuff is going
to come in and out but this is a sort of
a starting template with what we're
working with you saw it when it was
empty now it looks fantastic I think so
you guys saw the gear chest all the
stuff that's in it fantastic
organizational tool we have all the
carpeting and all the furniture and
things like that
we have the poker table you guys saw the
poker table and why it's a poker table
and then of course the dream desk over
there and all its glory the couch lit
more foam a little bit more furniture
you saw the entertainment system
obviously the TV over there you have the
couch you have the carpeting all that
sort of stuff all the foam and I got
some more tables you got some more gear
you got some desks you got the
production area you've seen it all now
thank you again I just want to take this
opportunity to say thank you for
everyone who's been watching his videos
you saw the plaque as well super
important to me but yeah that's pretty
much it as far as the tour goes
hopefully there will be more stuff like
this to come thank you for watching this
one talk to you guys the next one pace
you
[Music]
you